6 24 on your monday morning you know las
vegas boulevard is proof of the old
saying things can get worse
before they get better got a double
whammy painting a perfect picture of two
projects happening at once
once from the county ones from the city
hope all you junior traffic buddies
remember that sahara
is the dividing line between the two so
here's the latest starting with clark
county let's go ahead and look at
northbound las vegas boulevard
down to one lane from spring mountain up
to resorts well now that's not a long
stretch
but it is still a traffic snarling
squeeze play
the good news if there is any this
week-long lane closure marks the
beginning of the end of this
part of the project so those closed
lanes they are getting repaved
started last night supposed to last
until 10 a.m friday
now to the city's work north of sahara a
little hundred foot stretch of wyoming
next to las vegas boulevard that's
closed pretty much for the rest of the
month
but probably the bigger effect on
traffic one lane only in each direction
for las vegas boulevard at wyoming try
casino center or maine to get around but
it is a tough ride in that whole area by
the way
okie is back open after a month-long
closure in april
you know national work zone awareness
week was last week but please don't take
frustrations out on the men and women in
orange it is a tough gig buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight at eight news now
dot com